what is your take on this well a first
thing to say is it's a very sad State of
Affairs that obviously one feels for a
Hugh in in hospital and one also feels
for uh his wife and family and I know
Vicky as well you know appeared on
programs she's produced both of them
excellent journalists you know whose
work I I admire
my take though is there's going to be a
lot of recriminations now they're going
to be people saying well the sun should
never have done the story uh and uh I
would take the count of you I would say
that
people such as yourself such as
ourselves on television who hold others
to account for their behavior have to be
prepared to be held account for Behavior
not just on the yardstick of criminality
I mean there are a lot of people whose
careers have been ended a long way short
of criminality because it was felt that
they were bringing the organization
which they represented into into
distribute so you don't think the
yardsticks should be what was illegal
then because that is what some people
are saying right they're saying that
actually look nothing illegal has
necessarily been done here the police
say that there's nothing to talk about I
mean I'm I'm not saying these
allegations are true but
on the face of what the sun said and the
sun didn't actually ever alleged
criminality it says that
a man approaching 60
paid large amounts of money to a young
person under 20.
for some sort of exchange of illicit
material and that subsequently he phoned
that young person up and threatened them
now I think most people would regard
that as fairly representable behavior
I'm not saying that's true for
themselves says that nothing
inappropriate happens well as reported
by the sun this young person is clearly
a very vulnerable person
um who is according to the son someone
who has a very serious drug problem
so I would have thought that what they
say themselves is probably less reliable
than what their parents have said in
this case and then we do have the
interesting extra piece of information
which the BBC put out yesterday again
not alleging criminality but alleging
that the same presenter
had made threatening phone calls to
another young person so all I'm saying
is I think this is behavior which
you know
if I'd done it or you'd done it I think
we would be held to account by our
employers do you think that presenters
then people in the public eye if you
like that you know TV presenters in
particular should be held to a different
standard than from the general public
yes I you know there is this whole
question of the right to privacy but I
think people who are in the public eye
and by definition if you're presenting a
news program every night you're in the
public eye if you are subject to
personal profiles right talking about
your life and and your experience
because that's good publicity for you I
do think you expose yourself more to
examination than than someone who's
leading a quite low self-wear although
as you know you work for the news of the
world once I mean you know people we've
never heard of who do uh you know
shocking things they can find themselves
in the newspapers as well yeah although
I think I feel like the the Privacy
standards have changed have changed
quite fundamentally that I think is one
thing again which we should look at I
mean people are saying oh you know
privacy standards aren't tight enough I
would actually take the other view I
would say that
the whole business of
the Sun not being able to name this
person and still us not really knowing
the full details of what went on
has resulted in a kind of legal standoff
over five days which has damaged
everybody including you and you know had
the story been published he could have
come out and said
not true and effect is all over and the
consequences for the sun probably would
have been certainly that it would have
been sued and had to pay out a lot of
money and possibly as happened to the
news of the world over phone hacking it
might have gone out of business what um
what do you think about the BBC's role
here do you think that the BBC has
questions to answer and I guess that in
their defense they would say that they
did try to contact you know the parents
of the I mean I think they've been
caught out I think it's possibly
understandable but you know with
hindsight
a fairly serious complaint was made and
it does surprise me where I over that
period since May the 19th it's not
really clear that they spoke to Hugh at
all about it and now they get lots of
complaints about a lot of people but I I
think Tim David probably accept that you
know they should have done that that
said I think
once the sun went to it with allegations
I I think the BBC's handling of this has
been exemplary I mean their news
Operation has reported it as you know
just as uh firmly as Sky News uh and um
they have been prepared to
hold themselves to account for for the
way they've behaved so I I and
you know that one interesting thing
yesterday one of the things which sort
of tipped this case was the decision of
the BBC to tell us about the second
young person
who allegedly was or they say they had
evidence that he had been phoned by uh
with the person we now know is you and
there was some kind of coercion in in
those exchanges we don't know the
exchanges and also yeah but they told us
they told like they were effectively
threatening to expose it yeah but the
BBC told us that it was about the same
person which they didn't have to do
and and that seemed to me that you know
that showed
a certain amount of impatience within
the corporation what would you say to
some people who think look this is a
gross invasion of privacy this is a guy
who is now in hospital with mental
health issues his family's life have
been ruined the sun is an organization
that is always going for the BBC and of
course you Adam Bolton are going to
defend the sun because you are also
doing work for talk TV and for times
radio
well I wouldn't work for them if I
thought
you know what what people were doing
wrong I think people do make mistakes I
you know I wouldn't defend a lot of the
things which have happened at uh Fox
News for example but I take the view and
I'm someone who've had my own
private life you know double page
spreads in in tabloid newspapers someone
saying that if you do take action you
have to be prepared for the consequences
of of daylight being cast on it people
can make their own judgments whether
they think it's particularly comfortable
or not what would be wrong
is if this is all made up and fabricated
and it's not true but so far we have not
had
any denial specific denial of the
allegations raised against the person we
now know is Hugh Edwards by anybody by
his wife or anybody else they certainly
said they're going to respond so at the
moment it looks like it's uh as indeed
the director general of the BBC said
legitimate public interest uh thanks
very much Adam always good to talk thank
you for coming on the machine